[Music]
there was an historic hire in the nfl
this week the washington football team
announced jason wright will be its next
team president
wright a former player and partner at
mckinsey and company is the first
black person to hold that title in nfl
history
at age 38 he's also the youngest wright
joins washington at a tumultuous time
in july more than a dozen former female
employees made allegations of sexual
harassment
against team officials the team also
dropped redskins as its name following
decades of criticism
all of this amid the uncertainty of
playing in the upcoming season
surrounding the pandemic jason wright
joins us this morning from his home
in virginia jason good morning and
congratulations
thank you so much it's a pleasure to be
here with you all right well it's good
to have you um
a lot to talk about here i do want to
start with the latest news though
because your coach ron rivera told the
team on thursday night that he has
cancer
can you talk quickly about how ron is
doing and how that changes your job
moving forward
sure i mean he's doing great um both
physically and psychologically
spiritually and i think you've seen that
and what's come from him he's
he's a rock um you know emotionally um
and he's got such clarity of vision his
message has been look i'm gonna do what
i need to do
and let's keep it moving let's keep it
moving forward and that strength has
spread to the team and the staff
doesn't change anything for me except
that i know i really i already knew we
really need to take care of our people
in a different way
and do culture in a different way and be
people-centric i just needed to jump
into that
quite a bit earlier to take care of our
folks because it's hard for everybody in
the community
jason when you talk about that about
being people-centric and taking over
what we just referenced some of the
incidents that have gone in
gone on within the team how do you go
about
changing a culture that's a huge thing
to undertake
yeah it is a big thing to undertake but
frankly it's something that every
organization needs to do to remain high
performing and gratefully
i've been able to do that over the last
seven to eight years you know with my
former company
helping organizations get on that
journey i think you know fundamentally
it's at the individual level about their
mindsets their behaviors
the incentives around why they do their
work and then
transparency a culture that shines a
light
on the behaviors that we want in a
positive way and shines a light on those
that we don't want in the culture
and help to move it into a positive
direction and we also got to get things
right
very technically in the process and
policy sort of way
and the investigation will very much
help us with that and jason you know
we mentioned the historic nature of your
hiring and i heard that you said you
were happy you landed
in this role at this time why
i guess there's a few things number one
the the opportunity to really
shape things for the future of this
franchise are massive you know we're
getting ready to
establish a new identity that's going to
inform the way
that we you know impact the world the
way that we engage
charitably the way we engage with fans
and design the fan experience and that
is
a massive opportunity with great and to
work with great and talented people at
the club to do that
you know we're navigating a covet season
which is complex
tricky and i'm eager to help us navigate
that um
and there's so much opportunity and down
the road we get to build a new stadium
so there's so much about this
that feels like you really get to put
your imprint on something lasting
that it's an exciting thing to be a part
of
jason michelle miller here you sound so
excited but
i have to ask washington dropped that
historic name
redskins as its nickname after nearly
90 years what type of input will you be
looking for in a new name and
and how soon can we expect to see one
yeah i mean again it's so much more than
a name it's
it's so much more than a logo it's it's
an identity and because it's so
important and because it's going to
inform so many things we need to have an
open collaborative what i've been
calling a community-based process
engaging the fans the ones who really
embody the identity of the club out in
the world
they need to be engaged substantively
and over time we need to engage our
players staff sponsors
and also the leaders in the dmv area
because it needs to represent the dmv i
mean that is the area in which we're
located
um and so it's going to take some time
uh and
uh and i think uh it at the end whether
it's the name that
my friends want or my kids want or
whatever it is everybody should be able
to see
their fingerprints on the process and be
united in
the go forward identity jason i don't
envy the number of things on your plate
uh right now but again we do uh
we do congratulate you and really
appreciate you joining us thanks so much